today's video is sponsored by nordvpn
give yourself options online go to
nordvpn.com
bio to get a two-year plan at a huge
discount plus a free gift more on them
in just a bit
we never sleep that was the slogan that
greeted everyone who walked through the
doors of the most famous detective
agency in the world the pigmentons not
to mention that their logo of a vigilant
unblinking eye gave the world the term
private eye the detective agency was
founded by alan pinkerton a scottish
immigrant and a subject for today's
video he came from humble beginnings and
he led a quiet remote life building
barrels until fate thrust him into the
middle of the action and as it turned
out pinkerton took to adventure like a
duck to water
[Music]
alan pinkerton was born on the 25th of
august 1819 in glasgow scotland in one
of the poorest and most crime-ridden
areas of the city known as the gorbals
he was the second of two sons of william
pinkerton an isabelle mcqueen alongside
robert pinkerton who was five years
older than him his father's job is
somewhat uncertain some sources say he
was a police sergeant others say that he
was a jailer either way what mattered
was that william pinkerton was injured
on the job and he died when alan was
still a child leaving the family in dire
financial straits both pinkerton boys
had to find work which meant that allen
had to forego finishing school in order
to support his family allen showed up in
the 1841 census with his occupation
listed as journeyman cooper aka a barrel
maker while his older brother was a
blacksmith for some reason a
nine-year-old boy named john robertson
is also listed as a part of the
household although we're not exactly
sure where he fits in since the census
didn't include the relationships between
the family members reckless also show
that alan pinkenton married the
following year to a woman named joan
carfrae another native of glasgow the
two stayed married until his death and
their three children together while
working as a cooper alan pinkenton
became involved in chartism a movement
for reforms that benefited the working
class as you might expect the government
was not too thrilled with this
development and tried to suppress this
new crusade as much as possible although
many charters protests were peaceful
there were occasionally dustups with the
police things took a turn for the worse
in 1842 after the chartists gathered
over 3 million signatures for their
petition to be discussed in parliament
yet they were still turned down this led
to a wave of strikes and riots
throughout the uk and the state
responded in kind by arresting many men
involved with the chartist movement
following a scuffle with the law alan
pinkerton found that roy warren had been
issued for his arrest so with few other
choices he decided to leave scotland
under the shroud of darkness and sail to
america with his new wife and begin
another chapter in their lives given his
circumstances it's bitterly ironic that
the pinkertons themselves would
eventually become
anti-union-hired goons used as tools by
american industrialists to oppress the
working class
pinkerton's arrival to the new world was
inauspicious to say the least he had to
work as a cooper on the ship in order to
pay for his passage for himself and his
wife after a four week voyage the vessel
got caught in ice off the coast of nova
scotia forcing all the passengers to
leave everything they had behind and row
to safety in lifeboats in picking his
own words by the time the trip came to
an end in montreal they only had their
health and a few pennies the newlyweds
intended destination was chicago because
pinkerton had a friend there old bobby
fergus from the gorbals however they had
to spend an extra week in montreal so
the cooper could work a bit and earn
enough money for the trip to illinois
things went better for them once they
arrived in chicago fergus allowed them
to stay with him until they got settled
and even found allen a job with lill's
brewery once again as a cooper this was
their life for about a year or so
eventually though pinkerton thought he
would be more successful if he owned his
own cooperage consequently in 1843 the
couple relocated to the small town of
dundee in kane county illinois which as
you might guess from the name was mainly
inhabited by scottish immigrants there
alan pinkerton built a little cabin for
himself and for joan next to the fox
river right in the path of ranchers and
farmers traveling to and from the market
he also had a shed where he toiled every
day from sun up to sundown wake up at 4
30 go to bed at 8 30 seven days a week
no drinking no smoking no dancing no
shenanigans of any sort just all barrels
all the time that was pinkerton's
regimen and with that kind of dedication
his cooperage business thrived his wife
considered those days the best of their
lives but destiny had other plans the
career switched a private eye landed in
pinkerton's lap by chance he knew of
this little remote island that had good
trees which he often visited for lumber
one day in 1847 he noticed that somebody
else had been there as well and had left
behind the remnants of a campfire
pinkton's curiosity was peaked so he
returned several times all sneaky-like
trying to see who else was coming to a
secret spot after a few failed attempts
during the day he decided to try it at
night and he hit pay dirt pinkton
stumbled upon a ring of counterfeiters
he notified the cane county sheriff
luther dearborn and together they staked
out the island again after the sheriff
witnessed the criminals first hand he
formed a posse and took down the entire
ring pinkerton received a lot of the
credit for the bust but even so he still
intended to return to his old job
however a short while later he got his
second case once again without him
actually looking for one the owner of
the general store in town asked him for
help identifying another counterfeiter
pinkerton was reluctant but he agreed
not only did he identify the criminal a
man named john craig but he also gained
craig's confidence and arranged for a
deal in chicago where the counterfeiter
was arrested ultimately craig escaped
custody after bribing a policeman but
pinkerton's reputation was made after
that the cooper still wanted to go back
to cooping but this time he wasn't as
sure as before all of a sudden life in
the middle of nowhere building barrels
from dusk till dawn seemed a little
boring therefore when sheriff dearborn
offered him a position as deputy
pinkerton jumped at the chance he still
built barrels but he swapped his tools
for a cudgel when the sheriff had need
of him around the same time pinkerton
became involved with the underground
railroad the secret network used to help
slaves escape into canada or the
american free states as a staunch
abolitionist pinkerton remained involved
with this movement for decades and
offered his home as a safe house this
brought him into conflict with the
dundee baptist church they already
weren't fans of him because pinkerton
was not a religious man but he also
wasn't the calm and subtle type alan
pinton was a roaring angry scot and if
he had a problem with you you best
believe he'd let you know rather loudly
the relationship between the two sides
worsened when the elders of the church
began accusing pinkerton of selling
ardent spirits when in fact the cobbler
was a tea totaler who never touched
alcohol pinkton started to get fed up
with life on the frontier and even his
beloved cooperage business was getting a
little too monotonous but faye once
again intervened and pinkerton was
offered the position of deputy sheriff
in cook county headquartered in chicago
he accepted the spot and soon enough he
sold his cooperage packed everything
into wagons and moved to the big city
now a quick question how many times have
you been on the internet and noticed
creepy ads that seemed tailored to your
internet search history or speaking of
search history how many times have you
been on the internet and worried about
somebody perhaps even your government
tracking the websites that you visit
fortunately for you today's video is
sponsored by nordvpn which is helping to
give internet users all the tricks and
tools of a proper 21st century online
experience you may have heard me talk
before about what nordvpn can do for you
encrypt your internet data move your
online activity to another location with
just one click either for superior
security or new streaming options and
all of that is still true nordvpn has
more than 5000 servers spread throughout
60 countries but vpns give you access to
so many more options than just new tv
shows having trouble connecting to
social media where you live nordvpn want
to buy a movie that's cheaper somewhere
else nor vpn want to route your
connection through multiple servers just
for double layered protection yeah lord
vpn with nordvpn you can do it all and
that includes utilizing their threat
protection upgrade which blocks ads
eradicates web trackers checks for
malware and more right now as part of a
special deal you guys can get a two-year
plan at a huge discount plus an
additional month for free and if you try
nordvpn and change your mind they offer
a 30-day money-back guarantee all you
got to do is head to nordvpn.com forward
slash bio again that's nordvpn.com
forward slash bio for a two year deal at
a huge discount plus a free bonus gift
on top of that or just follow the link
in the description box below and now
back to today's video
this time pinkerton worked full-time as
a deputy sheriff and he impressed a lot
of people with his courage integrity and
love of a good fight even when it was
against armed thugs this earned him
quite a few enemies and even an attempt
on his own life when someone tried to
shoot him from behind fortunately for
pinkerton he was in the habit of walking
with his left arm behind his back so the
bullet hit his hand and didn't penetrate
further the chicago daily democratic
press reported of the incident the
pistol was of large caliber heavily
loaded and discharged so near that mr
pinkerton's coat was put on fire two
slugs shattered the bone five inches
from the wrist and passed along the bone
to the elbow where they were cut out by
a surgeon together with pieces of his
coat for his efforts in 1849 pinkerton
had the honor of being appointed
chicago's first police detective he only
held the position for one year though
before leaving due to political
interference as he put it but his
reputation was enough to immediately
secure him a new post as a special agent
with the united states post office once
again pinkerton excelled at his job and
earned mentions in the local press which
boldly proclaimed that as a detective mr
pinkerton has no superior and we doubt
if he has any equal in this country with
that kind of praise being lavished upon
him the ambitions of the former frontier
cooper grew and soon enough he'd quit
his job with the post office in order to
open his own detective agency in the
early 1850s alongside chicago attorney
edward rucker alan pinkerton founded the
northwestern police agency quickly
rebranded to the pinkerton national
detective agency in order to take full
advantage of his name recognition
contrary to popular belief though this
was not the first known private
detective agency in europe french
criminal terms criminalist eugene badock
whom we've already covered here on
biographics fyi beat him by a couple of
decades and even in america there was a
pair of saint louis policemen who opened
their own private guard service during
the 1840s the first years of the
agency's existence were fruitful and
efficient but not exactly full of
high-stakes skin of the teeth action
most of their work was done for the
ever-expanding railroads and involved
either protection services or theft
investigations this was the main course
complemented with side orders of fraud
counterfeiting bank robbery and even the
occasional murder the company's initial
success and steady growth allowed
pinkerton to build up a network of
underlings that he could trust including
kate warren america's first female
detective oddly enough pinkerton's most
exciting exploit at this time did not
even include his detective agency but
rather his anti-slavery activities
pinkerton was well acquainted with john
brown arguably the most radical
abolitionist leader in the country who
was more than willing to use violence in
order to free slaves brown was executed
in 1859 after a failed attack at harpers
ferry virginia where he intended to rail
the federal armory arm the slaves and
stage a liberation movement that would
extend as far south as possible john
brown's failed raid became a poodle
moment in american history leading up to
the civil war but he had a lesser-known
successful raid earlier in the year
which involved allen pinkerton in
january 1859 john brown led a raid in
missouri liberating around a dozen
slaves however his band killed a farmer
during the raid so they had the u.s
marshals on their trail as they sought
to reach canada in the early hours of
march the 11th 1859 the entire group was
in chicago banging on alan pinkerton's
door pinkerton took them all in no
questions asked but if they were to make
it to canada they needed money for food
clothes and supplies more than pinkton
himself could provide even so the
detective resolved to get that money one
way or the other he knew there was a
chicago judiciary convention scheduled
that day so he sent two friends with a
subscription list of all the city's
prominent abolitionists who would be at
the meeting they however returned
empty-handed saying that the delegates
refused assistance at that point
pinkerton took matters into his own
hands he tucked his revolver under his
coat and traveled to the convention hall
where a hush silence fell over the crowd
as soon as he entered pinkerton's voice
boomed throughout the room and he said
gentlemen i have one thing to do and i
intend to do it in a hurry john brown is
in this city at the present time with a
number of men women and children i
require aid and substantial aid i must
have i am ready and willing to leave
this meeting if i get this money if not
i will bring john brown to this meeting
and if any u.s marshal dare lay a hand
on him he must take the consequences i
am determined to do this or have the
money everyone there knew pinkerton
better than to call his bluffs so slowly
but surely almost every politician judge
and businessman in the room approached
the detective and dropped a bill in his
hat a few minutes later pinkerton left
the conventional with 500 to 600 and
then he escorted brown and his troop out
of the city
when the american civil war erupted in
1861 alan pinkerton fought on the union
side no surprises there given his strong
feelings about slavery he served as head
of the union intelligence service for
the first few years of the war under
commanding general george mcclellan who
already had a cordial relationship with
pinkerton from their pre-war days when
mcclellan worked as a railroad engineer
and threw a lot of business pinkerton's
way the intelligence agency served as a
forerunner to the u.s secret service but
its most famous some would say infamous
moment actually came before the civil
war even started when pinkerton and his
network of spies may have saved the life
of his new president-elect abraham
lincoln it became known as the baltimore
plot and ostensibly it was an attempt to
assassinate lincoln while passing
through maryland on his way to his
inauguration as the 16th president of
the united states as we've said this was
before the civil war had started which
in the minds of many had become
inevitable at that point but some still
believed that they would be able to
stave off the succession of the
confederacy if they got rid of lincoln
as you're probably aware link was not
assassinated in 1861 anyway and since
nobody was ever convicted and no solid
evidence was ever found there is still
ongoing debate whether or not the
baltimore plot was even real the idea
that lincoln wasn't very popular in
slave states is hardly a shocking
revelation immediately after winning the
election scores of hate mail and threats
began pouring into his office enough to
give twitter a run for its money but it
was samuel morse felton president of the
philadelphia wilmington and baltimore
railroad who heard rumors that something
more concrete and sinister was being
planned because alan pinkerton had
extensive experience providing
protection for trains and his aggressive
anti-slavery sentiments were beyond any
doubt it was natural for felton to turn
to him for help the detective used
several of his agents to infiltrate
rallies hang out secret societies and
any other pro-slavery meetings and
gathered enough information to believe
that the threat was real and that the
attack would happen in baltimore so why
baltimore well in february
president-elect abraham lincoln had
embarked on a 70-stop railway tour of
the country starting in illinois and
culminating with his inauguration in
washington d.c that included a lot of
places where he could have been waylaid
but baltimore was the perfect spot for
two reasons one maryland was a slave
state full of people who hated lincoln's
guts and two there was a city law that
forbade steam engines from passing
through town so even if lincoln was
aware of a plot against him he still had
no choice but to get out of his train
get into a horse-drawn railcar ride that
until the end of town and then get out
again and enter a waiting steam train
that created a lot of opportunity for an
ambush and pinkerton became convinced
that an assassination attempt would take
place in baltimore it was on february 21
1861 that pinkerton met lincoln for the
first time and brought the threat to his
attention the president was in
philadelphia in the middle of his
whistle-stop tour and were staying at
the continental hotel the problem was
that lincoln's itinerary and schedule
had been published in the press so his
would-be killers knew where he would be
to the minute pinkerton urged him to
change his routine and make an
unannounced pass through baltimore but
lincoln was reluctant to do so however
later that same day he received a letter
from senator william h c wood his
soon-to-be secretary of state who had
investigated the threat on his own and
pretty much told him the same thing as
pinkerton this swayed lincoln so the
following evening the president secretly
met with pinkerton and the detective
escorted him to the train station
lincoln put on a disguise and boarded a
different train that passed through
baltimore at night once the president
was out of maryland pinkerton wired a
telegram that simply said plums
delivered not safely which presumably
would make lincoln the nuts meanwhile
the president's retinue and his family
boarded their scheduled train the
following morning and lincoln made it
safely to his inauguration kate warne
the aforementioned female detective
accompanied the nutty president on this
trip according to legend she never
closed an eye while lincoln was in her
charge hence the pinkerton slogan we
never sleep
whether or not the baltimore plot truly
existed we cannot say but it certainly
convinced lincoln of pinkerton's
detective bonafides which was why he was
put in charge of union intelligence
during the early days of the war
pinkerton personally led the
investigation that exposed aspiring in
washington however he didn't really
cover himself in glory when he was sent
to the front lines alongside the army of
the potomac it turned out that military
espionage done amidst the chaos and
confusion of war wasn't really his forte
it wasn't for lack of bravery several
times pinkerton went into enemy
territory himself together intelligence
despite the high likelihood that he
would be recognized however his reports
with estimates on enemy size and
movements were often filled with errors
or exaggerations and during war a kind
of stuff was quite important at the same
time pinkerton found himself trapped in
a political war he was an ardent ally of
the aforementioned general george
mcclellan but mclennan and lincoln
didn't get along at all eventually the
general was relieved of his command and
when mclennan left so did pinkerton even
so following the war demand for the
pinkertons was high however by this
point the company grew to the point that
alan pinkerton mostly delegated to other
people he rarely did any grunt work
himself and spying was out of the
question since he had become too well
known furthermore in 1869 pinkerton
suffered a stroke that nearly killed him
and left him temporarily paralyzed so
even though he eventually returned to
the office his days of personally
chasing down criminals were over he led
his sons robert and william pinkerton do
most of the heavy lifting that being
said the pinkertons and some of their
most notorious cases after the civil war
in 1866 they began pursuing the reno
gang who were responsible for the first
peacetime train robberies in the country
on this occasion alan pinkerton did join
in the hunt and he almost got shot twice
for his troubles but managed to escape
unscathed both times during the early
1870s the pinkertons were put on the
trail of the infamous jesse james and
his gang this case however gave the
detective agency their biggest black eye
with the public their first failure
occurred in 1874 when an undercover
detective named joseph witcher was
identified and murdered by the james
gang the vengeful pinkerton was out for
blood so his men organized a raid on the
james farm in january 1875. in a
foolhardy move one of the detectives
tossed an explosive into the house
killing jesse james eight and a
half-year-old brother archie with the
blood of an innocent child on their
hands the pinkertons were vilified in
the press and alan pinkerton gave up
chasing jessie james suffering a very
public and humiliating defeat in the
minds of the average working man the
pinkertons would soon gain a sinister
reputation not due to the botched raid
but something else entirely their
violence against the labor movement just
like he loathed alcohol and slavery alan
pinkerton was steadfastly anti-union
which in his mind did more harm than
good to the working class during the
mid-1870s there was a famous case where
a pinkerton agent named james mcfarland
infiltrated an irish working-class
secret society named the molly mcguires
collected evidence against them and got
20 of them sentenced to death for their
roles in violent labor conflicts from
that point on the pinkertons became the
go-to service for every rich
industrialist in the country who wanted
to ensure that his workers didn't
unionize but there was no more espionage
counterintelligence or any other kind of
detective work involved the pinkertons
were simply armed goons there to break
up any would-be strikes almost always
using violence alan pinkerton defended
his actions until his dying day which
occurred on july 1 1884 some said that
he died from gangrene of the tongue
after biting it during a fall but others
reported a more mundane cause of death
such as a stroke on malaria after his
death his sons took over the company and
maintained their strike breaking
services overseeing some of the
bloodiest labor union crashes in the
history of the country that resulted in
hundreds of deaths and injuries and
forever tainted the pinkerton name
[Music]
you